This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford Post-Do and Pathology, Naturopathic
Doctor
Hello, hello everybody. Welcome to Daily
with Doc and Becca. My name is Becca
Dukes and as the producer and host of
this program, I am honored as a
certified
naturopathic practitioner and certified
holistic health coach to have a resource
that doesn't take your power away. It
gives it back. Makes you more empowered,
informed individual.
Because, you know, our bodies aren't
made
in a way that they're supposed to fall
apart when they're supposed correctly.
We're going to learn some more about
that today. So, if you were invited to
this program by somebody specific, make
sure that you get back with them. They
cared enough about you. Take the time to
say thank you. and they are going to be
your number one point of contact when
you have questions in regards to things
that you can do to help yourself. So,
make sure you remember who shared this
program with you. And as you're
listening, if you can think of somebody
that could benefit from the information
on our program, please share, share,
share. But most importantly,
make sure that you subscribe to our
channels as we are all across the
worldwide web and social media. We are
here and investing our money and health
and time
so that you can have a better health
journey. So again, my name is Becca
Dukes and I am excited as today we are
going to be diving into something that
so many people struggle with many times
silently
whether it's chronic health issues,
exhaustion, confusion, you know that
feeling of why is nothing working
and so much more. So, our guest today,
he didn't just study this, he lived it.
And for 30 years, Brian Crater battled
depression, fatigue, brain fog, chronic
pain, and addiction, searching for
answers the conventional system could
not provide.
But instead of giving up, he leaned in.
He questioned everything, which I
absolutely love. And through decades of
research, trial and error, he uncovered
what truly creates health and what
actually restores it. So today, he is
fully recovered without relying on
pharmaceutical medications and is now
helping others break free as well from
some of the same cycles. He is a
certified holistic health coach who
specializes in understanding cravings,
addiction, and why willpower alone is
not the answer. So, if you've felt stuck
or
if you've tried everything and still
don't have the answers, this show is for
you. You are in the right place. So,
please help me welcome to the screen
Brian Crater. Brian, hello. Welcome. I'm
so excited to have you on with us. As
you know, you as I get to know you and
hear little bits of your story and read
it. Uh you've gone through quite a bit
that looking at you, you'd never guess.
Well, uh, yeah, thanks for having me.
Pretty exciting.
>> Well, absolutely. We I'm glad that you
agreed because I know you're stepping
out of your comfort zone. Um, and that's
okay. That that gives us the ability to
be able to help and reach more and more
people.
So my first question to you, I would
like you to take us back
thinking of when your health was at it
was at its worst. Was it what was it
like?
Oh, probably the lowest was probably
when I would get into this routine of
buying
Twinkies and Ding-Dongs and eating the
entire box in a night along with, you
know, cigars and chewing tobacco and um,
you know, whiskey and Yeah, that was
that was a that was an evening for me.
Yeah,
that was pretty bad.
>> Okay. So, so some people think, well,
what's wrong with that?
>> What
for you
eating that way, having that lifestyle?
How did you physically feel?
>> Uh, well, it was it well, one thing, uh,
at the time I would have severe energy
swings that was probably, you know, the
the blood sugar was probably totally out
of control. Um but yeah, my energy would
go up and down and of course there was,
you know, depression and all that with
it. Um and I I did that for quite a few
years actually.
And well, yeah, I actually before I came
on here, I had to think about um what
what I was really doing. And I I did get
into pills um quite quite a bit. Not not
heavy, but off and on over maybe 10 year
period. And um yeah, it's amazing how
your brain can kind of normalize that.
It's not a big deal, you know, I don't
>> really have a problem. But that those
were really making me sick. So yeah,
that was that was not fun.
>> Now we had mentioned depression. Did the
depression lead to these habits or did
these habits open up the depression?
probably more maybe
I don't know symbiotic maybe one
affected the other.
>> Okay.
>> And I was you know hooked on fast food
too. I was I went through a few years
where I ate fast food every single
night. It was like a routine right? You
you go and get out of the house and
um get your get your fast food.
That was that was that was really bad.
That was that was pretty sick from that.
>> Okay. So, so was that a matter of
convenience or you just didn't feel like
cooking
or didn't have time?
>> Probably just a habit, you know, like an
addiction. I was addicted to that, too.
I think um the, you know, the flavors
and that the artificial kind of flavors
and that kind of food can I think a lot
of people are probably pretty heavily
addicted to that lifestyle, too.
Mhm.
>> So, did did you figure something that
must be wrong and you sought out um
doctors to see if they could help?
>> I I really didn't. Um well, that was I'm
going to go back years ago. Um back to
1999.
I broke up with my girlfriend and the
doctor said, "Oh, here's here's a sample
of Paxel. That should help me out. I
said, "Okay." took that and it made me
feel terrible, like numb, made me numb,
>> kind of emotionally detached. It was
weird. So, I quit that within a few
days. So, that and then that got that
got me thinking about
how how these these the standard MD
system just doesn't know what to do a
lot of the time.
And yeah, I started digging in deeper
with more research and reading books and
yeah.
>> So, so you do do you think that that
that um experience with the paxel is
what really opened you up mentally?
>> Um yeah, it really made me think. Made
me think. Yeah, I got got me really
curious, I think.
So going from numb, emotionally
detached, and just kind of there,
you're like,
you acknowledged that that's not how you
wanted to live.
>> Well, right away. Yeah, it was it was it
was awful. It was it was just a bizarre
um feeling
what that of course I knew that's what
it was. It's obviously this this pink
pill doing this like this is dumb. And
it it was only a few days when it
started to affect me like that.
>> So I guess maybe it was maybe probably
how I was raised. You know, my grandma
would she was somewhat of a of a health
conscious person. So that probably
that's all in my subconscious. My my the
way I was raised, I think.
>> So I kind of knew. Yeah.
>> Thank goodness for grandma.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. She well she was
born in Oklahoma
raised on the farm and raised her own
garden and you know canned. She was a
canning expert
and yeah had kind of I lived with her a
few years and she had quite a quite an
influence on me. She would juice she had
a juicer
>> juice carrots. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Awesome. Awesome. So
>> yeah,
>> I I know a lot of people that are
listening um probably have felt
like this where you get into this rut of
habit uh good habits and bad habits.
We're looking more towards the bad
habits. We've got some type of situation
that happens in our life that causes
some depression that um you know we we
seek out help and that help is just not
we know inside that help is not quite
what we needed. So
you you questioned the system
and instead of just questioning it, you
started reading books and getting more
back to possibly what what grandma was
doing
and you had mentioned that you know this
is not quite right like you were a
skeptic.
Sorry for that skeptic. Um, so what were
you most skeptical about?
>> Um, well, well, it seems like, you know,
I' I've been I've been to the standard
MD a few times. Um, and they always seem
to have um
the these odd questions like, "Oh, are
are you depressed?" and
um you know here here's some uh here's
some paxels medication and and um they
don't for me they don't seem to have a
lot of answers. It's
I don't know.
So they were basically trained to take a
pharmaceutical but not so much as to any
in-depth information.
Well, this that visit was bad. I mean, I
I told him I broke up with my
girlfriend. I was sad and he gave me a
um it's a sample pack of Paxel and I
think that was probably something that
was going I don't know if they're still
doing that now, but it's I guess it's I
could just assume it's kind of a system
to get you hooked on these these
medications. and
>> it was one of those free samples at the
time that was probably going on pretty
heavy in in the in the late 90s.
Um,
and
>> I I remember going
>> I remember going to the doctor in in the
' 90s and trying to figure out pain and
they would give me a sample of this and
thank goodness I didn't pay for the
allergic reaction but still
>> those samples
I mean, for somebody that that didn't
have a negative reaction, they could be
addictive, right?
>> Yeah, for sure. For sure. Um,
you hate to uh hate to go that
>> direction and I try to stay away from
from conspiracy theories um much as I
can, but kind of seems like sometimes
it's it's a system that they have set up
to kind of kind of get you get you
hooked in there.
Mhm. For sure.
>> And I don't I don't like to be
controlled. Um so maybe that's what the
skepticism was that kind of a I have a
rebellious kind of a personality. So um
yeah, just
>> so there's skepticism,
>> there's skepticism, there's conspiracy,
and there's misconception.
Did you identify some misconceptions?
>> Um well I think well when after the
paxel situation I I got a I found a book
I got really curious. I found a book
called the anti-depressant fact book
which I highly recommend. So basic I
forgot the name of the doctor but he was
an expert witness.
>> Mhm. and he he said that he has no um
connection to pharmaceutical companies,
so he could tell the truth about the
effects of pharmaceutical drugs. It was
it's an incredible book. I'd recommend
it and it really I read it cover to
cover. I just devoured it and um it it
tells the truth and it's it's it's
pretty bad um that people need to be
aware of.
>> So, what are some things that really
stuck out for you?
I mean, you read the book cover to cover
the
>> book. Well, that it's um he one thing he
said was that these these and
anti-depressants are basically a
chemical labbotomy.
>> He actually said that and that's that's
really scary. So, basically damages your
brain what these drugs do.
>> Yeah.
>> Um so,
>> yeah.
>> Okay. Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> No, there there's Yeah, it's been a
while since I read it, so there's a it's
it's very it's very detailed, very deep,
and it's it's very shocking
what he knows. I knew he's probably
deceased by now, but yeah, that was
about I think came out right around year
2000, but that one that really made me
curious. Really opened my eyes for sure.
So opening your eyes to how a system
looks at the symptoms of depression, not
the root cause. And then taking and
basing, you know, you give a pill, you
look at the different physical things
that are going on, not necessarily the
chemical things that are damaging within
the body.
Do you think that the combination of of
some of the habits that you had plus
adding in the the pharmaceutical may
have I know you were only on it for a
couple more days may may have had um
kind of like a compounding effect.
Um,
well, it's pretty amazing that even even
um with all this curiosity and the
knowledge that I was starting to
acquire, I didn't I didn't quite believe
it. I guess
like I I I talked to a lot I think this
is a common problem. A lot of people
have this where they hear something, it
just don't it doesn't sink in and they
kind of go back to their old ways and
then they just go back to the doctor and
>> you know he'll he'll he'll fix you right
up, right?
Yeah.
>> Did you ever read the adverse side
effects, the possible side effects, and
think, "Oh, that'll never happen to me."
>> Um, well, I know that. Well, yeah,
exactly. That like the the pain pills,
they're very addictive. You got to be
careful with those. And um the Paxel, I
didn't even the doctor didn't even tell
me anything about any side effects. and
paxel has some very severe side effects
and he told me nothing about it. I'd be
like, "Okay, doc, I'll take them."
Because you I think, you know, you trust
the doctor
um give you the good stuff, right?
>> Well, yeah, absolutely.
>> I mean, they've gone to school for eight
years. They've studied the body. They've
got this diploma and and I know some
amazing doctors. I'm not dissing
doctors. I one of my good friends is a
retired oncology surgeon. I just
absolutely adore her. Um and and others
that you know they they have a good
heart. They go into it all in to help
people
not realizing that some of the things
that they learn doesn't really help as
much as as maybe society thinks that
they do.
So you had talked about um you know
reading the book. After reading the
book, what are some of maybe the dietary
things, lifestyle things that that you
started using or making a change within
your own life?
>> Well, I actually I always um I was I was
supplementing with vitamins here and
there. I started doing that I think in
the 90s, but
I would I would take them here and there
and and that was the quality of the of
the vitam I'd always question that
how do you know what is a you know good
supplement what isn't and and then I
would
switch brands and take this take that
take more take less and then just give
up I think I gave up for a few years and
you know but I was
I think I was eating pretty bad pretty
bad diet. That probably probably had a
lot to do with how how I was feeling
too. That's for sure.
>> Yeah. Now, you had mentioned
supplements, not knowing if they if they
work or not. Um
what what got you to
um look at the different supplements?
Can you unpack that for us?
Um
probably well I I mean it's probably
like hey I'm taking these I'm taking
these and I wasn't um tried to feel a
little better but to feel worse and it
it seemed to work but not really and
yeah
so that quite that went on for quite a
few years and so I you know I've had
these um cravings for
quite a long time probably since um I
started uh using tobacco at age 13. So
that kind of stuck with me until a
couple years ago.
>> Yeah.
>> Using tobacco like chew or cigarettes or
>> Yeah. Well, I used every form every form
available.
>> Every form.
>> Yeah.
>> You didn't play baseball, did you?
>> No. No, not really. No, it wasn't.
Yeah. Yeah, but I've always had these
these cravings and sugar, you know, then
the then the pills and then the the
nicotine. It's it's been there for that
was so that was 38 years I was hooked on
nicotine.
>> Mhm.
>> And of course the sugar came with it.
Like I said, the Twinkies, the
ding-dongs. I mean, it's usually people
have just a few ding-dongs. I I had to
have one or two boxes, you know.
>> Wow. So, so for you, because I know
there's a lot of people that use uh
smoking, keep their hands busy as an
appetite suppressant. Didn't quite work
that way for you.
>> Oh, it No, it was cravings. Food
cravings. Yeah.
And nothing.
>> Okay.
>> Mhm.
>> So, what stopped your cravings?
Was it willpower?
>> Well,
no. No, it wasn't. I I I actually tried
um
I tried to quit quite a few times. 2015
I was able to quit for a year
and of course they relapsed. It didn't
last long. Um
and I was I was actually taking um plant
derived minerals at the time. H.
>> So, but what's interesting is is now I
know that the minerals can help u help
with cravings. Um, but I at at that time
I didn't know I didn't know that in
2015.
So,
yeah. So, I had
>> Well, what got what got you to look at
taking plant derived minerals? Because I
mean not very many people hear about
plant derived minerals. You know why
wouldn't I just take a a a vitamin or
you know calcium or magnesium which are
minerals but we're talking plant derived
minerals with 60 different minerals
trace micro macro.
What got you to look at that?
So yeah, I mentioned my grandma was a
bit of a um health consscious
I don't want to say health nut. That's
kind of I don't like that term, but I
guess she was, but she was raised that
way on the farm. And of course that I
think that rubbed off on my dad. He was
also health consscious. And back in in
in the '9s, he came came home from work
and he had a cassette tape, the Dag
Doctors Don't Lie. And we we listened
that and got really excited.
about about what Dr. Wallik had to say.
Um,
so yeah, we started taking Dr. Wallik's
products and then for some reason it
just quit doing that. Got away from it.
So I guess I'm going back and forth in
the timeline here, but
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah.
>> So you were a cassette tape kit.
>> Yeah, that was when I think when it
first came out. Maybe 96 I think. Yeah,
97 around that time.
Yeah, between 94 and 96 is when they
really started taking off.
>> Yeah,
>> that's awesome.
>> That's awesome.
>> And I got to add, I think why I quit
taking the the products was I had a a
local naturopath
and I I I actually gave him the
supplements to I asked him, "Is it are
these okay to take?" And he and he
actually said, "No, don't take those.
Those are not good. take mine the way I
sell in my office here. And so I did
that. I took his for a while and then
quit. And then I that's that's what
threw me off.
>> So here's a question for you. So you
were taking Plant Dive Minerals, which
we think are top line, top shelf. You
went into another supplement line.
Did you feel a difference when you
started and then when you stopped?
the Oh, when I switched over to the the
Don Metropaths
supplements.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, yeah, I think so. I didn't notice
any I guess I didn't notice any
difference and I just quit. Yeah.
You know, and then
yeah, kind of went went from there,
which so that that from that doctor, he
really distracted me. Mhm.
>> I guess he did. He was pretty good, but
he didn't know everything he should he
should have known, I think, at the time.
>> Well, and now
you've chosen a career of educating
them, right?
>> Exactly. Yeah. It's it's it's I mean, he
was really good at he did like ozone
therapy. He did um vitamin C drips,
things like that. So, he did a lot of a
lot of interesting um useful things, but
he got some details wrong that that
threw me off. And
>> what's interesting about this whole
thing is that you have to have
everything in in order. Like, if you're
taking what I learned, if you're taking
supplements and you're not absorbing
them, you're just wasting your money,
that's a big deal. Of course, Dr. Wallik
says intake is as or absorption is as
important as intake.
So I right now there's so many people
millions of people taking these you know
supplements and they're not absorbing
any of it just wasting their money. So
yeah,
>> I I know in my research as I was looking
at the different supplements because I
took supplements for decades and never
felt a bit of difference. And then when
I got digging into it, it's like, oh
well, this this study shows that in this
popular brand, I might be getting 6% of
what they say is on the label. And then
the label is nothing compared to what
we're looking at for the Tangy
Tangerine.
So I think absorption, the the quality
of the product, the form that it's in
really has or makes a big difference
cuz like you I mean you you can't really
identify a huge difference between
taking them and not taking them.
And I'm like I don't feel any different.
Why am I wasting my money on something?
Until I found Dr. Wallik and then that
was
night and day difference because I was
absorbing. It was something my body
could absorb.
>> So
>> that reminds me I got I got to mention
that the um 89% of sports supplements
tested did not accur accurately label
their ingredients.
I wanted to talk about that one which is
really interesting. So this is a Forbes
article came out in 2023
and anybody can find this just look at
look up Forbes.
So yeah they found 89%
were not accurate not accurately
labeled.
And then as I was as I was finding this
article, looking this up, I found
another one saying, "Oh, um 50% of the
supplements on Amazon, sorry Amazon, but
this is not my article. Um someone else
did this and they, you know, they bought
these supplements and took them uh and
put them on the on the the machines."
>> Mhm.
And um yeah, they found that the the
labels what's on the label doesn't quite
match what's in the in the bottle. So,
you know, I like Amazon and Amazon's
great, but I think uh it's kind of
looking to me like
it's it's not just them. It's that has
an issue. I think it's
it's all over the place. It's it's
probably nationwide and everywhere that
it's a problem,
>> right? and they're just a distributor
for for different brands
>> that you know are are retail on the
market. So it's not so much about Amazon
although so many people are going to
Amazon because of convenience
the speed of delivery you know sometimes
you can get a better better price but
when it comes like you said you know
that article
what was on the label wasn't in which is
one reason why I absolutely love
Youngevity is because there's third
party testing
to make sure that what it says on the
label is actually what is in the
canister or the bottle.
So
um Key has a question and you had
mentioned about taking um vitamins
um but were you familiar with the whole
fractionated
um type supplementation
co-actors
any of that dynamic when it comes to
taking vitamins?
>> No. No, not really.
I of course you know everybody hears oh
the you know 90 essential nutrients but
I no I didn't quite understand the
that concept. I mean I I would take a
multivitamin on occasion.
>> Mhm.
And
no, I didn't really have a full grasp of
that until I got went through the
certification course and then I of
course yeah figured that out.
>> So speaking of the certification course,
that's the um Institute of Holistic
Health Certified Holistic Health Coach
course. Is that correct?
>> Right.
>> And did you learn anything?
>> Yes, I did. I mean, I I already knew
quite a bit already, but um yeah, the
the course kind of filled in the gaps
for sure.
>> And were there a lot of gaps or just a
few?
>> Uh quite a few. Quite a few. Yeah. Um
it kind of tied tied everything
together. And also, um just talking to
other coaches, I I've been learning more
and more and more. And the more I think
the more I learn, the more um fascinated
I get, more interested I get in in human
health and how how it interacts with
nature and food and culture and various
things
because a lot of the food that that's a
big problem is is is
I don't know what you call it, cultural
food,
>> things we all
consider normal and acceptable to eat at
the dinner
Some of those are not necessarily
healthy and are actually making us very
sick.
So that's that's a hard thing to get to.
The peer pressure at the dinner table um
serving the acceptable foods, you know,
I guess that that's a whole another
show. I think
>> that Yeah, that's that's a whole another
show. So but but let's let's take a
look. Okay, you've taken the course and
in taking the course looking back, can
you identify
and maybe
um things that your body was telling you
that led you to start taking vitamins,
thinking, "Oh, there's a deficiency in
this." or or give you more of an insight
as to what was going on with
um your food choices, your cravings,
your the addictions that you had. Can
can you see how they could have been
deficiencies?
>> Yeah, I think well one of the big I
think one of the big motivators uh I was
still using nicotine. I was vaping. I
switched to vaping um last
six, seven years.
And when I got uh certified, I thought,
you know, I I can't be a smoking health
coach. That doesn't make sense.
And also, it it kind of motivate
motivated me to take the to start taking
the full protocol. I I've never taken
the full 90 at at the right doses. So, I
decided, you know, I'm I got to give
this a try. And I I did. So, yeah, it's
powerful stuff. I mean, I I had to kind
of cut back a little bit for a couple of
weeks until I got used to it. Yeah, it
this Yeah, the the YMI products are
definitely at a at a higher level.
There's no doubt.
>> So, you felt a difference?
>> 100%. Oh, yeah. Yeah, it actually Well,
yeah, it was
pretty dramatic. Yeah.
So, let's talk about that dramatic.
When you say dramatic, what are some of
the things that were going on that that
uh helped you know that you were
actually putting something in your body
that was helping or good for you?
>> Oh, geez. Well, one Oh, that's a good
question. One thing I noticed was when I
was I was walking in the mailbox and
noticed, man, my legs feel so much
lighter. Like,
>> like they weren't nearly as heavy. This
that was strange. I didn't really expect
that, but So, yeah, definitely the
energy improvement, I think. Um
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> What else?
>> Well, I got I got to a point where um
I'm vaping and doing the full protocol,
right? Vaping and it kind of got to a
point where I wasn't sure if I was
getting too much nicotine or not enough.
And now that I look back, it's kind of
interesting. Wallik says um to get
addicted to nutrition.
And that's kind of what was happening.
So the nutrition was replacing somehow
or or pushing out the nictine cravings
or just cravings in general, all of them
pretty much.
>> And so it it got confusing there for a
while. I was like, well, do I need
because everybody who's who's doing
their dope or smoking or drinking,
they're they're you're regulating it.
you can tell if you're getting too high,
too low. Um,
and it was weird when I was doing the
nutrition. It it I was um not sure if it
was too high, too low. I couldn't tell
what was going on. It was very
confusing.
I thought that was pretty interesting.
And eventually, I just kept I mean, I
was taking pretty high doses of this. I
was doing, like I said, the full the
full protocol. And yeah,
eventually
>> it kind of pushed the the the cravings
out. Yeah. It was it was really amazing.
Very impressive.
>> So they were they interrupted your
habit.
This your every day they interrupted and
it's like okay do I want this? Do I need
this
type thing?
>> Yeah. Exactly.
>> So So where are you now?
Well, I just um yeah, I eat a lot
better. So, I've cut out, you know, the
bad foods um which is which was very
tough. I I did I did the full protocol
and I cut out gluten, which is which is
a really tough one because you get into
habits. Um
you know, everybody's everybody's hooked
on u hooked on bread, you know, and
gluten. It's it's a tough one. And I
understand why a lot of um a lot of
doctors don't want to tell people that
because
it's not what they want to hear.
>> And it was great time. It was it was
kind of a shocking adjustment. I was
like, "Okay, what am I supposed to eat?
What am I how do I cook?"
>> But then I it was no problem. I figured
out, oh, there's so much gluten-free
stuff out there now. It's so much
easier. Um then I figured out, oh, I
just can get this bread and do that get
that cracker and eat it. Yeah. It's just
Oh, it's just like like Wallick says,
you just have to make a slight
adjustment. And he's right. It's not
that big of a deal once you get used to
it. Yeah.
>> So, it's like just trading this for
that.
>> Yeah.
>> But reading labels and making sure that
what you're trading for is not putting
more bad stuff into your system.
So, you had mentioned something about
your skin which I thought was quite
interesting.
>> Yeah, it's it's it's it's very
embarrassing. I think a lot of people
deal with this cuz I you can see it the
oily skin on the face. Um it was it was
for some reason it was
it was really extreme for me. Um of
course it it looks horrible. It's like
shiny, you know, it's And I tried doing
research getting online and I saw
somebody just well, you just there's
nothing you can do. You just have to
wash your face, you know, every whenever
whenever it happens. But it got so bad
to this is pretty embarrassing. U but it
got so bad. Um it was like a real
concern like when I would be invited to
a party or to go out or do you know hang
out with friends, it's like well what am
I going to do? I got to figure out where
the sink is and how am I going to
because it's very embarrassing
the oil.
>> Um it maybe it's easier for a woman
because you can you have the purse and
you have the the pads and whatever you
can clean. Um but for a man it's like
what how you know I can't I don't want
to carry a purse around with
facial supplies you know.
Anyway, yeah. So
I don't have that issue anymore. It's
perfectly normal. Um, it doesn't do
that. And now I'm learning more about
it. Ben Fuches talks about how your your
skin can become overactive or maybe
overstimulated somehow by maybe what is
it? Sugar or things like that,
>> bottled oils,
>> nutrient deficiencies, things like that.
And um I think I think essential fatty
acids have a lot to do with the the oil
production. I'm not sure. Maybe it's
maybe it calms the skin down somehow. I
don't know. Um it's very very
interesting though.
So yeah,
>> it it is nice to
to be able to look back. It's like where
you were where you are now is I don't
see any oily skin.
And like Olga says, it's kind of funny.
You were a smoking health coach. Are you
still smoking?
No, no, I'm not. Actually, what's
interesting is I've had a couple people
that I was close to pass away. And
>> that's, you know, a lot of stress from
that. And even with that stress, I I
didn't even think about going back to
the nicotine, which which is incredible
to me.
>> Yeah.
>> Because I was addicted for so long, you
know, 38 years. Um, addicted and Yeah.
So I'm able to well I I regulate it with
the nutrition with obviously eating
better and I just don't crave it. Not
even my sugar addictions have been or
cravings have been
drastically reduced. Yeah. It's it's
pretty pretty amazing that that's why I
keep doing it. I think that's why I keep
buying the products.
>> So So you're not Yeah. like going for
the Twinkies and the Ding-Dongs and then
eating a whole box in one setting
anymore?
>> No. No, not at all. Not at all. Once in
a while, you know, I think those those
cravings are always kind of there a
little bit, but
>> it's it's 95% better. Yeah. Than it was
100. Absolutely.
>> And do you do you now realize or
understand that those cravings were
caused by a blood sugar issue?
probably very likely.
>> Yeah. So, if you were starting with
somebody right now who again some of the
things that you uh experienced were the
addictions to nicotine, all types, um
the alcohol, sugar.
If you had somebody or yourself
from what 30 years ago sitting down with
them right now,
what would you say to them
to help them understand how these habits
are feeding each other and how they
could break free?
Um,
>> well, the problem is if if they just
don't know what to do. That's I think
the main key. Like you don't if you
don't you don't know what you don't
know.
>> Mhm.
And I think that's that's what um we're
all trying to do here is is Wallocks
warriors, you know, is get get the word
out and because people just don't know,
I think what questions to ask and and
Oh, that reminds me like we live in this
age of um information overload
and people Yeah, they're doing their own
research, right? But they're totally
confused. The things I see in social
media, my social media feed is is just
there's some crazy stuff. I think people
are getting very confused. Probably more
confused now than they were say 30 years
ago.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. That's a big problem.
And then they and then of course then
the Facebook um echo chamber groups
that's a big problem too. Like if you I
tried going in there and and saying a
few things but I immediately get kicked
out because they don't want to hear
different opinions. So the problem with
that is the you know they just form
these echo chambers of of misinformation
and that's that's a big problem too.
Um so those echo chambers of
misinformation could it also be people
jumping in to have you know group pity
parties?
>> It's possible. Yeah. Uh, I mean it's
it's I think that's these are deep
philosophical or philosophical
psychological um questions like what is
going on in people's minds
um like they're looking for answers but
they're the wrong answers and they're
not being they're not being helped
>> or they're not the answers that they're
willing to do.
So again, I see that goes into I' I've
talked to people like, "Well, you got to
quit the gluten." And this and they say,
"No way. No thanks. I'm out."
And that's that's too bad. You know,
it's I I know it's tough. It's tough.
It's it's a real lifestyle change, but
it's I think it's when you're suffering
like I was. I mean, being addicted to
sugar and nicotine and pills and all
that and that's not that's not fun. So,
>> no. So, do you think that your addiction
was more physical, emotional, or
nutritional?
>> I think it's uh nutritional because I
had, you know, a couple the two
closest people
um in my life die and I didn't go back
to the
to the the nicotine. So, I don't know.
What does that what does that tell me?
It tells me it's more it's Yeah, it's
more
like a physiological issue.
So that that tells me that you
neutrified yourself. You were
emotionally more stable
to not fall back into those physical
habits
maybe. And so, well, and now since I'm
more educated than I've than ever
before, since I heard that tape in the
'9s, um, I just have a better
understanding of how to
kind of regulate my own
physical health.
>> Mhm.
>> So, that that's a huge advantage,
knowing how to solve my own health
issues instead of going, you know,
running to the doctor like most people
do. They they get a cold and run to the
doctor and then he does the tests and
gives you the pills and
yeah,
which is expensive too by the way. Very
expensive,
>> right?
>> That way a lot of people figure they
spend a lot of money trying to figure
out what's wrong with them and the
doctors can't give them any answers and
it's because it's nutritional. It's not
something that a pill can with chemical
pill pharmaceutical can fix.
So,
um, so Brian,
if somebody is overwhelmed with the
symptoms like you are,
>> where should they start?
>> Well, that's that's a good qu. Well, if
they were talking to me, I would I would
know what to tell them. Do what I did.
>> Okay, I'm talking to you. Tell me. Tell
me.
>> Um, yeah. I would say, well, you got to
quit the the 12 bad foods.
Unfortunately, cuz a big one is the
fried food. Everybody loves fried food.
I love fried food. I love fish and
chips. That was my favorite.
Unfortunately,
can't have them anymore. But it's so
worth
it's so worth it. So worth it. So,
so we got to we got to convince people
to to do that and that it is worth
giving up those delicious flavors that
hurt us. Like says, we're slaves to our
taste buds and we have to use
logic and research and knowledge and
science
to um prevent ourselves from getting
sick from these again culturally
acceptable foods which you know a lot of
fried food
>> like we see that what they they a lot of
fried food in the south and it's a
cultural thing and it it's taken you
know 50 years off their lives.
But that's not good. Then I tell them,
hey, you know, you got to get you got to
get some good nutrition, too. Some
quality supplements. That's really
mandatory.
And try to try to avoid um
hate to d keep digging Amazon, you know,
but I think a lot of people are I just
talked to someone who the other day who
said she's buying, you know, $300 worth
of supplements on Amazon and she's still
chain smoking.
and she's got issues, health issu, many
health issues. And so I'm thinking,
well, if those supplements are working,
you know, why are you why are you chain
smoking?
>> They're buying them on Amazon and
>> it looks kind of it doesn't look real
good as far as the um what what
researchers are starting to find. You
know, there's no there's no legal
conclusion yet. we have to it's
allegedly you know but it looks like
it's more than one group finding this um
and I know it is convenient ordering on
Amazon but
you got to you got to get some you got
to get a quality quality brand here and
you have to absorb them too right
>> right so I think yeah you need quality
you need absorbability but you also need
to know what exactly is it that I need,
which is where a certified holistic
health coach comes in and works with
you, figures out what are the root
causes
of the symptoms that you're experiencing
and then works at it and modifies as
needed.
Is that
what you is that a good way to approach
it?
I I would I would concur. Yeah, that's
that's how you do it. And yeah, because
you know, our bodies do change from day
to day. You have to you do have to
adjust.
And um yeah, I just thought about I was
thinking about this the other day, like
we
show people what to do and then they
they won't need us after, you know, 6
months or so. They'll know exactly what
to do, which is which is pretty awesome.
I think the the medical system that we
have, it it it wants to kind of get us
hooked into
systems that kind of benefit the system
>> instead of benefiting
>> the patient. Yeah.
>> So, so supporting
the body
has has many benefits.
What do you think was the biggest
benefit for you healthwise? I mean, you
were able to get rid of the addictions,
but healthwise, what do you think was
the biggest benefit that you yourself
experienced with the supplementation
and removing the bad foods, which folks,
if you don't know what the bad foods
are, no wheat, barley, rye, or oats. And
Dr. Wallik has added in buckwheat
because of the fagopyrene which is a
chemical that burns. It's toxic. It can
burn which you put it in your system.
What's it going to do? It's going to
burn all the way down and all the way
through creating a lot of the symptoms
of like um digestive issues. We're just
going to go with that instead of medical
terms. Um no bottled oils. Bottled oils.
So Brian, when I say bottled oils, what
oils do you think of?
>> Well, that would include olive oil,
unfortunately. And this I've had a lot
of arguments with people about this.
They just there's there's a you know,
there's a there's a internet doctor
coming. He just came out with his his
own special olive oil, healthier than
the others.
You got to swig this olive oil and a lot
of people are doing this and
and yeah, I mean I I thought it was
healthy, too. And it it it is really
some of these things are really hard to
accept and understand. Well, why are so
many people saying, you know, whole
grain bread is healthy? We we've heard
that for many many decades.
Um eat your waties. Um it's it's, you
know, make it make it big and strong. Um
yeah
so one thing as a baker
when I'm making anything it's always as
it's always requiring baking or uh sorry
vegetable oils that's bottled oil folks.
So you got the vegetable oils, the olive
oils, coconut, peanut, corn, soybean.
Um removing all that. So when I when
somebody asks, "Well, why would I need
to remove the oils? They're supposed to
be healthy. They're coming from plants
and vegetables." What's your response?
Oh, well, I would I would tell them,
well, sure, it's it's healthy in the in
the seeds, healthy in the plant, but
once you expose it um and it hits
oxygen, then it
it starts um deteriorating just like u
when you slice open an apple, starts
turning brown within a minute. So,
>> yep.
>> And banana bananas too, they everybody's
experienced that. Um, yeah.
And like it, but these things are so
difficult for people to understand
because we've been we've been taught
these things are healthy and
they're they're they're good to eat. Eat
your vegetable oil. And I think the word
vegetable really throws people off. It's
Well, it's vegetables is healthy, you
know.
>> Yeah. Absolutely.
>> Yeah. And it's but it's hard because
it's it's everywhere. I I was in the I
would encourage everybody to go to if
you're near a restaurant supply store,
go in there, look around, and that's
what you're eating in restaurants. And I
love eating eating at restaurants,
but man, they put a lot of a lot of bad
stuff in their bad food, right?
>> Well, big bottles, you know, big bottles
of of like butterflavored oil, great for
on the label it says great for frying.
No refrigeration required.
Um but yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> 100%.
>> Right. Well, it is it is good to avoid
for sure because not only you want to do
no bottled oils because they oxidize.
You don't want to fry the food in it
because then you're overcooking the food
creating acryummites which goes right
into no well done meats. As far as red
meats go, of course, pork and um which I
limit pork considerably, but pork and
chicken, you want to make sure it is
cooked well. And you don't want to get a
bunch of lunch meats and processed meats
that have added nitrates and nitrites.
uh no carbonated drinks because it
disrupts the digestive system so that
the body can't break down the the food
well creating digestive issues. So if
you're always belching and burping and
always feel bloated and you know you're
drinking that even ginger to help soothe
your tummy, you're actually creating
more of a problem when it comes to the
digestive system and you don't want to
eat the skins of baked potatoes. So, I
wanted to make sure that as Brian had
mentioned the good foods, the 12 good
foods or 12 bad foods that you had an
idea of what those foods are. We do have
some hands up. Brian, you ready for a
couple questions?
Um yeah, I just wanted to add if if any
like what I say what I was saying about
it's worth it avoiding these foods
because uh one issue that we're all
becoming aware of is the the younger
ages of people getting colon cancer and
if you go on YouTube you can see people
younger people are starting to post
their stories of their their battle with
colon cancer and it's it's it's
horrible. It's really really horrible.
Um,
it just, you know, it's it's kids even
in their 30s
getting colon cancer and it's no one has
no one has any idea what's going on
here. Um, but I think uh I think we know
what's what's going on. And so that's
why I'm saying it's it's really worth
you don't have to go crazy with like I
I'll go to restaurants, you know, I'll
try really hard not, you know, to avoid
the the seed oils that they call them
now. But
>> Mhm.
>> I think it's worth making an effort to
Yeah. to kind of watch out for these
these foods and avoid them. But best you
can, you know, because
>> it's very real the the the diseases that
that are happening
to younger younger people. Um you it's
it's real, you know. So, I guess most
people don't worry about it until it
happens to them and then it just turns
your life upside down. So, yeah, let's
try try to avoid that if we can.
>> Absolutely.
you know, um, just real quick, you had
mentioned social media, and one of the
things that you've done on social media
has taken some common foods and then
shown a video how many tablespoons
of sugar are in each of these these
different products. So, uh, folks, you
know, look up Brian Creator on Facebook
or I think you're on Instagram
as well. uh and check out those videos,
like them, share them, get kind of like
a visual as to Oh my word, I can't
believe I'm taking in that much sugar.
So, let's go ahead and go to some
questions. Brian and Phyllis,
go ahead and unmute yourself. Come on
in. What question do you have for Brian
today?
>> Hello, Brian.
Um, I I want to say first, uh, amen to
what you're saying about restaurants.
And I find that almost always I'm better
off eating my own food that I prepare
and fix myself even going out to the
good restaurants.
I don't know what it is. I eat more than
I would or I it just seems to
automatically not be as good for me. So,
I appreciate your comments there and I
do want to thank you for bringing this
topic to us. I think it's a fascinating
topic and we need to get into it more
because it's pervasive. Um, but here's
the question that uh, Becca had asked
you and then you all got distracted from
it, but she asked what was the biggest
health benefit or one of the biggest
that you noticed when you uh, changed
how you ate and started getting the 90
nutrients? What really stands out?
Um, well, being able to control
cravings,
you know,
because my my sugar cravings were very
strong, too, along with nicotine. It was
it seemed like the two strongest ones
were nicotine and sugar.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, well, go ahead, please.
>> Those are those are the stronger ones.
Also, that um what really stands out is
my energy used to be really high and
low. Like I wouldn't know what from hour
to hour which part of the day I'd have
enough energy to move. And sometimes
yeah sometime I would just totally I
forgot to add this. I would just totally
crash and have to lay in bed about 3
days to recover.
Took it took several days. That that was
when I was eating all the fast food
every day. Yeah. It was really hard on
me.
Well, and you're talking about
recovering basic functioning and living,
which energy alone is is such an
important aspect of of everything we do.
If if you don't feel like doing
something, forget about it.
>> Yeah. So, that's that's a that's a big
one, too, is more steady energy levels,
which is really nice from morning until
until bed.
So, yeah, that's that's a really that's
a really big one, I think.
Thank you, Brian. I will drop off so
Keelley can get on here.
>> Okay.
>> Yes, Key, if you'd like to turn your
camera on,
what question do you have for Brian?
>> Um, good afternoon. Hey, Brian. Um, nice
to see you again today. Thank you for
being on the show. I'm sitting in my
kitchen. Sorry.
Um, the the question, um, I have a
couple questions really that I' I'd like
to give you. What would you define? and
I listened to the whole thing. Uh, what
was your breaking point?
>> Wow.
>> Um,
>> what brought you to your knees? What did
you get sick and sick and tired enough
of that it made you look outside of
yourself to search for something?
>> Well, of course, I always I always had
that knowledge, the Dr. Well,
acknowledge from the '9s, always in in
in the back of my head the whole time.
And um
>> and then I thought I thought, you know,
I got to quit this smoking. As I years
ago, I'd say by 50, I got to I got to
quit the smoking. That's obviously going
to kill me, you know. Okay. So, the
threat of your life, you know, they say
that when somebody is smoking basically,
you know, you're picking, you're it's an
oral affixiation. Then what happens is
why were you snuffing out your life?
Because something was calling you back
to life.
And you made a statement earlier. The
reason that I asked that question is you
made a statement earlier. You said,
well, you know, it's like that paradigm.
How do you get somebody to basically
make that mental shift because it's so
hard? You know, I just wanted to point
out that that's how you made yours.
That's one of the things that I heard
you say that really didn't come across
clearly.
And then the question is, so what was
your first win
after you made that mental shift?
>> Oh, first win. Um
well um I don't know what what do you
mean exactly?
>> Well I mean if you think about it you
had a blood sugar issue that you really
didn't know that you had. You knew that
you were craving sugar but also you know
like talk about pickup you know or
whatever. You're like the horse that is
you know eating the wood in the barnum
or whatever. That's sort of what you
were doing with the smoking as well. But
there was something in you that you were
paying attention to that guided you
along a process to get here. It's real.
It's I think that's part of your
testimony and your story of what you
have to give. Which really brings me
back to the fact is are you aware
um or how would you share the protocol
that you're presently on that got you
through that entire journey?
Because it's that protocol that if I
came to you today with blood sugar
issues, I I'm smoking. I can't control
my sugar. What is that protocol that you
have benefited from that has helped you
regain your life back
>> and would you be willing to share it?
>> Oh, the protocol itself. Um, well, it's
just you got to take all 90 essential
nutrients and stop eating the food
that's destroying the gut pretty much.
>> So, are you taking the uh digestion
pack, the sugar pack, the heart pack,
the healthy start pack? What are you
taking specifically?
>> Oh, um,
>> are you taking extra minerals? Because
one of the
>> oddly enough Yeah. Oh, that's a good
one. Yeah. Well, for the
the the the nicotine sessation at the
beginning, I was taking um maybe six
ounces a day of minerals. Yeah, it was
it was a very heavy dose.
Actually got up to 12 12 ounces per day.
>> Okay.
>> Just to
like Wick says, you got to saturate
saturate the body with it. Yeah, it was
it was pretty intense.
>> And did you take that with the healthy
body start pack or you you know either
the pig pack? Was there a particular
pack that you had picked that that you
would and again I'm coming to you you
know with the same issues that you have.
What did you do that I could actually
evaluate if I had the same um challenges
that you did that you have overcome?
>> I don't think I was taking the packs to
be honest. I would just buy individually
for some reason because I wanted because
I wanted the liquid osteo. It was just
Yeah. So I didn't I didn't like the
powder at the time or something. So I
didn't buy the packs. But
>> understood now.
>> I was doing the Oh, well um tangy
tangerine and osteo effects powder and
essential fatty acids and minerals. So I
I'm I got to take the minerals. I think
that really helps with the um cravings
for sure.
But now I'm down I'm down to a couple
ounces a day. Yeah.
>> So you're in the maintenance zone now.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. It's it's I
don't
So I'm actually uh two years. Nicotine
free. April 28th. This month. It's going
to be two years. Yeah.
traveler
>> and I don't um I'm not craving it at all
which is really nice because it was very
exp I hated going to that vape shop you
know and spending $100 it's very
expensive every few weeks
>> not to not to mention with vaping you
put those pin holes in your lungs and
you know you can recover from that as
well but I appreciate the fact that you
were vulnerable enough to share you know
your health challenges you talked about
you know the struggle that you went
through and the end result really comes
back to those minerals. Um, you know, I
think it's fabulous when you look at
what Doc has done, um, what his research
and his comparative pathology actually
have said to us because minerals make up
about twothirds of what we need to
consume in order to recover, renew
um, and step back into our lives fully
in wellness. But um, so congratulations
on your journey and thank you for
sharing.
Right. Yes. Yeah. It's exciting to
>> Yeah. I keep thinking, you know, it's I
it's it's so awesome, you know, I want
to just shout it from the the mountain
tops um to anyone who's willing to
listen.
>> Well, I am glad that you agreed to come
on with us and share your journey. And
again, 90 essential nutrients, Beyonce
tangerine, the osteo effects, the EFA
plus, that is the 90 foundation, adding
in those plant derived minerals. Now, I
have a question for you, Brian. Do you
like the plain, the cherry men's, or the
strawberry kiwi men's?
>> I take the plain because um it's Yeah.
Just I just mix it in with tangerine.
Yeah. With the just it and the flavor
amazing. It just disappears when you
dilute it enough. Yeah,
>> for sure. For sure. Thank you so much,
Brian. I know. Um, Bruce put on here
great questions. And when is Brian
coming back? So, I know it was this was
stepping out of your comfort zone. told
you we're gonna pull you out and get you
out there because you've got a great
story. And you know, unless you practice
sharing it like on the big screen,
>> then it's just going to be your story.
Let's let the world hear it. Like you
said, shout it from the mountain tops.
So, thank you so much everybody. I know
we had a couple other questions. Oh, a
comment. Olga says, "Young products are
highly addictive and seriously good for
your health, folks." So, if you're
looking for something to be addicted to,
you're in the right place, too, uh,
that's not going to make your legs feel
heavy, like Brian had mentioned earlier.
um and just add to
your wellness so that you can do what
you absolutely love to do instead of,
you know, feeling sluggish or not
knowing when you're going to have those
highs and lows in your energy. So, if I
could get the co-hosts up on the screen
with me, that would be absolutely
fantastic. So thankful that I don't have
to do this by myself. Brian, thank you
again for coming on, being vulnerable
and and just, you know, sharing your
story with us and that's what is going
to help so many people because
you're
well,
I did have to coers you into this a
little bit, but in doing that, you're
going to be helping a lot of people. So,
thank you so much, Brian, for that.
>> Yeah, I just want to add like what what
really I think drives me is is um what
what Dr. Wallik has done is just expose
the um just the the the truth. I mean,
it's just uncensored raw truth is is
>> what what he's done.
>> Yeah,
>> that's it.
>> That's it. That's it. And we love Dr.
Wallik. So glad that he is still here
with us on Earth. Even if we can't have
him on camera with us, we have to share
him with his family. I just got a text
message from the producer of the George
Nory Coast to Coast shows wanting to
know how Doc is doing. So Tom and the
reports that I get is he is enjoying
retirement
and spending time with his family. So,
we can't be absorbing all of his time.
Um, so we just give our love out to Dr.
Wallik and everyone who has experienced
the 90 essential nutrients.
We want to hear from you. So, if you're
out watching on any of the different
platforms, there's a way that you can
comment. Please let us know. I take the
90. Comment, let us know. Or if you
don't and you want to get back with the
person that shared this program with you
or put in a comment, I want the 90. Or
you can also call us as I do have a call
team standing by waiting for your calls
for those who were not referred to this
show by anybody else. And for those who
did not hear about Young or Dr. wallet
from somebody else. Cuz if you did, get
back with them.
8559493377.
Again, 855-9493377.
If you prefer to email, you can email
questions at dailywithdoc.com.
Again, that's questions with an
sdailywithdoc.com.
You can also find on dailywithdoc.com as
this program is sponsored by
dailywithdoc.com
the good foods, bad foods list. So, you
want to know what foods you should be
eating. Focus on those good foods and
just don't even put the bad foods in
your cart. It makes it so much easier.
You get the nutrition in,
you start losing the cravings for it
because your body's no longer starving.
Because folks, when we eat, eat, eat,
the body's just looking for nutrition.
So, when you give the body the
nutrition, you no longer need all the
calories that you're taking in. So,
thank you to my co-hosts. I have on the
screen with me now, Sherry, part of our
tech crew. Thank you so much, Sherry,
for all that you do and helping to get
things started and making sure that we
have volume.
Sometimes we
tend to not, but thank you so much for
keeping an eye on that. We also have
Ruth Ellen who is my production
executive production manager um making
sure that everything is rolling smoothly
and pushing everything out to the
different platforms here live on Daily
with Doc Do and Becca. We have
Marilyn. Things are bouncing around.
Marilyn who is Speedy Fingers doing some
great dictation in the chat that's only
available here live with us. We also
have Albert letting people in as he is
our doorkeeper, our gatekeeper joining
us from South Africa. And last but not
least, one of the pioneers in getting
Dr. Wallak on the air.
Miss Phyllis as she and her husband Andy
were very instrumental in getting Dr.
Wallik on the air along with
one of my friends, Michael Zerling,
lovingly known as MZ. So folks, if you
want to be part of something bigger than
yourself and help spread the message and
give hope and empowerment,
get back with the person that shared
this program with you and say, "Hey, I
want to be part of the family. I want to
be part of the solution."
That solution being giving information,
providing knowledge that helps people
choose and find and create
and claim a better health journey. So,
let's make it a better by the minute
health life.
Until next time, my name is Becca Dukes.
Thank you so much for joining us here on
Daily with Doc. And for those of you who
are hanging out with us in overtime, you
rock. Bye for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.